hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba blonde
you go I'm John I'm gonna need a star do
you guys know ten sexy horse horse you
know what I was crazy I know some that
are sexy horrors i I'm gonna transition
there's a channel called all-time movies
they are friends of John and I and they
have this video out top 10 sexiest
horror movie whoo I like it I feel like
maybe one of these can be a good date
movie to do my girlfriend although I
don't think she gets turned on by sex
scenes and movies which is a bummer I
don't either
you don't you don't oh you see Boogie
Nights okay I feel like it depends on
the sex scene cuz I feel like you have a
good argument there with Boogie Nights
but maybe you just haven't seen the
right sexy maybe maybe there's one out
there one out there maybe it's on this
way let's find out there's one in the
remake of Friday the 13th
yeah oh yeah we were all
[Music]
yeah sixteen year old Jesse arrives in
LA to pursue her dream modeling career
but soon her rivals become obsessed with
the new girl in the industry she's been
in town for like a minute
the neon demon is a planet Tara follows
various people trying to survive a
violent mutant zombie wars that were
created after a deadly biochemical agent
was released into the air I love this
movie but monetary is one of those
brilliant can be fun horror movies that
SOC exploitations movies made famous by
grindhouse cinemas naturally as part of
grindhouse
planet Tara consistently uses sex as a
way of demonstrating power and dominance
over others
this context gary oldman let's be honest
here The Hunger delves into the idea of
consumption mingling the idea of
companionship and murder it's incredibly
erotic man cheating with the threesome
is always hot the women's juice soon he
becomes embroiled in a very dangerous
game I'm a good guy okay I'm I turned on
number five the company of wolves
next up it's the adaptation of one of
Angela Carter's infamous inverted fairy
tales the company of wolves follows a
young girl who dreams that her sister is
killed by a mysterious wolf creature
from the forest
her grandmother warns her to stay away
from men whose eyebrows meet instead of
constant elaborate sex scenes spoiler
the company relies on an underlying
sexual tension that continuously builds
and builds throughout the movie it's
really quite incredible number four
thirst just out of the metals is the
2009 vampire movie by the incredible
Park chan-wook first tells the story of
Sankhya a priest he volunteers to take
part in a drug experiment in an attempt
to cure the deadly Emmanuelle virus
sang-hyun is infected with the disease
but miraculously recovers unaware these
also contracted vampirism this is a
glorious vampire movie but toys with the
idea of temptation released from his
world of responsibilities sangeun
experiences ability from social
restrictions to the embracing of
[Music]
suppliers
rather than risk feeding from
contamination and sexuality Tilda
Swinton and Tom Hiddleston have a
magnetic charisma on-screen it only gets
better as they need to relapse grow
stronger this movie is a painfully cool
seductive look into the world of
uncontrollable desire cat people are
naturally sexist of course cat people
tells the story of Irina who travels to
New Orleans to reconnect with her
brother he was a dark obsession with her
and a mysterious link to be a baby I
won't reveal anymore
relationships and I know what the guys
ankle any layoffs movie essentially
green inferno cabin fever Queen of the
Damned should've be on that should have
been on that list yeah bathtub scene
with alia and Stewart with a vampire
yeah come on all the homosexual
undertones going on in there isn't like
a sexy they had a movie on here that was
like there's no actual sex oh yeah
you're right there was a lot of sexual
tension in interview with the vampire
where the male characters which was it
was sexy it was specially Antonia
benders and Brad Pitt that scene was
just like no man
cruisin Brad Pitt those seem true oh
yeah boys just macking on hot stuff good
point and rice movies got left out yeah
yeah it was like 14 other vampire movies
on how dare you say vampires probably
hands down the sexiest of the horror
vampires are just sexy you know there's
their alluring they're just beautiful
they're magnetic they just because that
of all the other monsters are the
closest to being human - yeah they are
but they're like you defied human yeah
it's the only supernatural thing that
makes you sexy earth again the sunlight
sucks trick-or-treat that was a trick
for you guys that scene with Keanu
Reeves though no I don't know why I
haven't seen knock-knock that's cuz you
know being the fan of Keanu that I am
and that kind of movie what is wrong
with me I need to get on this there's
sex to be had and knock knock that's
forever yeah that's a horror movie where
the weapon is sex instead of like a
machete or something yeah I mean yeah
this is one of those girls is Eli Roth's
wife no way yeah and the other one is in
Blade Runner 2049 right yeah the guy is
in the matrix in the car you like these
guys need to redefine what they think
it's sexy some of the things are talking
about I'm like how is this possibly sexy
[Music]
thirst yeah the one that was from the
director oh yeah okay not like creepy to
serve like a lot of these movies are
talking about seem to deal with sexual
discomfort yeah and I don't find
discomfort of yes actually yeah I know I
feel like if I did there'd be something
I gotta check out about yeah
FairPoint man and I feel like in that it
was more like a fetish she sexy whereas
like it wasn't really honing in on like
your typical normal sexiness yeah
it's sexy but in that weird fetish way
yeah yeah well maybe they took the
horror comedy formula route and they
went well okay can't just be sexy it
also has to be horrific a little bit yes
I feel like species have any either of
you guys seen species no but I'm all you
have oh yeah I saw it what I actually
got her autograph natasha Henstridge oh
my VHS copy and I think I'm old enough
to have a VHS well I think this works as
sexy as you notice my creepy imagery
they were showing the guys who she's
sleeping with have no idea she's really
an alien there's a lot of seduction
build-up and there's sex stuff happening
I could see myself being a single guy in
that position being like yeah I totally
have sex with this girl you know and
then something horrific yeah but I still
feel as that that layer of sexiness
strongly apply knock knock I guess I you
I ever qualify knock knock I just don't
like that movie but in terms of with the
sexy hormone yeah because that's a whole
way that's all about temptation and
giving into something that is feels
wrong species that was cool like the
premise and the idea of having to like
evolutionarily primitively yeah like
that's remotely a and make sure that
your species survives that's interesting
because you know it is something that we
are like psychologically is what we do
in life I like bestiality and incest
no I can't you know born well the thing
also too is we haven't seen all of these
so maybe they're describing the movies
overall and maybe if you go and watch
them there's like one or two just lets
sure because the ones I have seen I'm
like able to just kind of sexy even
though that movie overall is like you
know very deliberately pasted and
they're very vampiric it's very sort of
cold and dark there's some sexy stuff in
that movie and
like Game of Thrones is kind of thrown
that at us
yeah been so weird we're kind of getting
used to it but it's not as a sexy thing
it said I still hear wrong no but it's
just more like oh yeah okay so that
happened
yeah but like the bestiality man I can't
get D led me on you ever had a crush on
an aunt or you never had a crush on an
uncle cat as a kid in a car was your
aunt never an intern uncle no no I've
never had a crush on an uncle aunt good
yeah me neither
yeah totally Greg thanks subscribe to
Anita star while you're at it click
everyone's notice you have so many
notifications they're gonna think you're
so popular things just dinking god
that's what matters no matter people's
popularity patreon is a website rihanna
is our website jump on it you should
jump on the patreon oh and send us your
jigsaw reactions tag us and start us and
stuff and stuff bye thanks for handling
it